[Music]
foreign
the ocean is a Mysterious World humans
know more about the surface of Mars than
the floor of the ocean and the sea
creatures who live there well even the
ones you have imagined you've imagined
them wrong take the mighty giant Kraken
bloodthirsty monster Sinker of ships
where are you even getting this Krakens
are majestic creatures and Noble
protectors I'm just Ruby Gilman normal
teenager for Generations Krakens have
protected the Seas keeping us safe from
the most power-hungry and dangerous
creature of all the mermaid yes the
mermaid but people love mermaids I love
you
they do people are scared
mermaids are selfish vain
narcissists I am gorgeous yes Queen the
worst of them all
are you okay I know your secret you're a
kraken hiding is a human you really
gotta go now and soon everyone will know
the truth
are you ready for your destiny I just
want to live my life
you have powers beyond your imagination
this is your moments Ruby
[Music]
I'm not gonna hide anymore
Grandmama I want you to teach me how to
use my Powers camouflage super speed
body armor let's see what you're capable
of
laser eyes yes they do pack a wallet oh
you're just a dumb team
mermaid knock knock no matter what the
challenge a kraken will always and serve
us all it's time to go big
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]